the auto shanghai matt is cool that
isn't on the road today he's reporting
for us from the 16th auto shanghai show
in china here on almost half a million
square meters of exhibition space
domestic and international car makers
are unveiling all the newest models and
the big german brands are here to of
course there are plenty of world
premieres at the show including a big
one from mercedes they learnt for Dale
Thomas Weber explains how SUV is used to
offer lots of trunk space as well as
off-road qualities but dimer has brought
an SUV here the GLC could pay that has
both extraordinary power and a great
visual presence optic oh cited guilty
copy the model was designed to further
extend mercedes already wide selection
of SUVs the concept car is 4.7 3 meters
long and one point 60 meters high its
massive 21-inch wheels add to the
imposing impression
Volkswagen plans to build more than 15
different electric models in China over
the next four years one of them is the
SI coupe a gte unveiled here in shanghai
for the first time it's a large plug-in
hybrid sedan
does it's thus far behind shackled
noises says this vehicle is positioned
between the sub compact segment with the
passat and maggot an and the larger feet
in segments appealing to both those who
drive and those who are chauffeured it
was developed exclusively for the
Chinese market that's a shame for
customers elsewhere because the
designers and developers of the SI coupe
a gte have really created a winner here
Wendy I'm vocalist matter says if you're
looking for a really big SUV just forget
all the European and American models
like the Cadillac Escalade the chevrolet
suburban and the hammer because this one
is bigger than them all the tank-like g
pattern is too big for european streets
more realistic is BMW x5 xdrive for TE
it has all of the course the versatility
of a full-size SAV by the carbon
footprint of a very small car and a
zero-emissions capability for those
urban environments over time we're going
to bring this technology right out of
the I brand across all the other models
and the x5 is just the first step in
that the x5 hybrid is BMWs first volume
produce car with plug-in technology a
lithium-ion battery can power the car
for up to 30 kilometers solely on
electricity I needed my just wants to
show us something at auto shanghai
that's not a car it's a pair of glasses
a concept development mini augmented
vision wear it when you drive and you
have integrated displays with additional
information at your disposal
Portia is content here in China with
sales booming the company is
underscoring its strong presence here by
debuting the style edition of the 911
carrera and Boxster in Shanghai the
style Edition vehicles have a striking
appearance and their standard versions
have lots of what would be extras in
other cars
let's go backstage for this exclusive
little number the panamera exclusive
series has its own closed-off room at
the show the luxury four-door sports car
is a strictly limited edition of 100
worldwide Shanghai has also hosted the
world premiere of Audis q7 e-tron the
first plug-in hybrid model in the queue
family it was designed and developed
specifically for the needs of the
Chinese market howdy is showcasing to
study the prologue allroad also a
plug-in hybrid electric power is
everywhere here Chinese government has
really pushed to develop the country's
infrastructure explains out its chief
executive he foresees the battery
electric car and also the plug-in hybrid
assuming tremendous importance here in
the next few years adding the plug-in
increases the power of Audis prologue
allroad to a total of 540 kilowatts
these condo Houghton matters enjoyed
seeing the new developments here in
Shanghai many of them will soon be on
the market and a few already are but
some of them will remain out of reach
for almost everyone like this winner of
last year's 24-hour undermine the Audi
r18 e-tron Quattro in Audi are acting
each honker at home
LS does it by our test driver reinhold
dives and offer equips that Audi's RS
stands for really strong 270 kilowatts
or 367 horsepower really Swift up to 280
kilometres now and really seen you eat
with 465 newton meters of torque that's
what you get with the Audi rs3 at least
on paper what can it do in day-to-day
driving and how does it perform on the
racetrack and what does it sound like
it sounds like outies greatest hits
after all out his first cuatro in the
1980s with its five-cylinder engine gave
the series its sporty image and the rs3
is definitely sporting its four-wheel
drive has a multiple disc clutch on the
rear axle so if needed you can direct
all the power to the rear wheels that
provides powerful driving dynamics
including slight drifts the compact
speedster goes for at least fifty two
thousand seven hundred euros and the
list of options is long for example you
can order carbon ceramic front disc
brakes they save quite a little weight
and deliver unmatched stopping power
but despite its outstanding performance
on the racetrack the rs3 was designed
for normal roads where its flap control
exhaust system and agile handling make
the lots of fun even without the carbon
ceramic brakes for maximum experience we
recommend driving where there's an echo
oz orange line hold admits that RS
actually stands for a lens port or
racing sports that doesn't have to mean
a bone rattler the rs3 has a comfort
setting for long distances accelerates
104.3 seconds slightly faster than a
Porsche 911 GTS only a super sports car
like a Lamborghini Ferrari or Porsche
911 Turbo Sprint's faster of course full
power takes full tanks far more often
our test drivers average fuel
consumption was 9 to 10 litres per 100
kilometers the rs3 isn't everyone's
taste especially in Nardo grey the
newest generation of the rs3 has two
oval tail pipes in the diffuser they
clearly mark the car as an RS model even
the standard brakes with their wave
design save weight and look really smart
performance and design are a unity even
under the hood
you can spend a lot of money on the
interior red seams and red inlays and
events are included in a nine hundred
euro design package
he knows you know test driver Reinhold
says RS stands not only for really
strong really Swift and really sinewy
but also for really steep because the
rs3 starts at fifty two thousand seven
hundred euros the competition BMW or
Mercedes are a tad lower but if you
think that's too expensive not everyone
agrees in 2014 Audi sold some 15,000 of
the predecessor model if you are going
to buy the rs3 vinyl recommends the
sport exhaust system for another eight
hundred and fifty euros your neighbors
will be delighted when you leave home or
return they'll hear two blocks away no
one needs to play this match for a
compact sports car neither for racing
nor for everyday use but the rs3 will
have emotional appeal for some people a
decision to buy will not be based on
sober consideration
the VW bus is a veritable design classic
it was originally launched in 1950 and
has since sold around 12 million units
now coinciding with its 65th anniversary
the long-awaited sixth generation is
hitting the market the lines ribs and
edges run continuously from front to
back with the entire body now appearing
to be a single element there will be six
new engines each with a fuel-efficient
automatic start/stop system
for the first time the display comes
with a proximity sensor the system
automatically switches to operational
mode as soon as you're about to touch
the touchscreen among the new equipment
options are a power tailgate a reversing
camera and 3-way adjustable suspension
prices for the multi van version are
expected to start just below thirty
thousand euros
this is BMWs testing grounds in miramar
in the South of France before discarding
the camouflage and fully unveiling the
new 7-series BMW gives the world a
preview of the most important
modifications for the latest generation
of the luxury sedan the upcoming model
is the product of a new engineering
approach and combining carbon fiber
reinforced polymers or cfrp with
aluminium and steel to set new standards
in weight saving design as well as
handling and ride comfort lace bashment
anymore lightweight construction is
crucial explains BMWs Michelle Alice
with the new model they've saved around
130 kilos the biggest contributor is the
body with a 40 kilo reduction for the
first time CFRP is being used not as a
visible exterior skin but in combination
with other materials as seen in the BMW
i8 a good example is the integration of
cfrp in the steel structure of the
b-pillar the roofline features a kind of
cfrp tubing the sister stucco here you
can see the carbon moving across the
roof from the a to the B and C pillars
across the whole passenger cabin this is
cutting-edge technology here the unique
aspect is that unlike previous profiles
there is no longer a core that helps to
generate the maximum potential for low
weight damn it does max amala get its
potential of cymbalta a house phone
and that in turn means a lower center of
gravity the result is the kind of
handling normally seen in smaller models
the 7-series now also boasts an addition
to the driving experience control
feature the adaptive mode
if I yet to mr. MA BMW's your span ass
is proud to present a world first in the
new seven series adaptive mode analyzes
the drivers steering and styled and use
of the gas pedal elves fire badal point
an old phone using sat nav data to the
system tells you where you are and
automatically computes the optimum set
up for the current driving scenario set
up automatic reduces Alderley Edge
Dillon another new function speed limit
info detects speed restrictions in
advance a further assist for the driver
is in madera BMWs Klaus Dora is driving
at the current permissible speed the car
is already displaying the speed limit
ahead he just has to touch a button to
switch to the speed allowed the car
slows down and he's exactly at the speed
on the side wouldn't he have been laude
the gershwin decay time sheet of ice
the car makers wanted the drivers
journey to be both energetic and as
comfortable and pleasant as possible the
next generation of the seven series has
also made advances on the ConnectedDrive
front the gearstick Storyful to new the
gesture control feature works by a
camera in the roof picking up a
particular hand movement and then
interacting with the vehicle it allows
us to operate functions you can alter
the entertainment system volume in the
vehicle by moving your finger in a
circle it's a universal gesture that
will always work regardless of what's
currently being displayed on the screen
Egbert how about but there are also
special gestures where the system
responds depending on the context when
there's an incoming call for example to
pick up and talk to the other person all
you need to do is this gesture to accept
the call our name and pan with your
session it's similar with declining
calls the simple wave of the hand will
redirect that call to his mailbox sort
of it the BMW display key is another
world premiere for a production vehicle
it allows the driver to park the car
without being at the wheel the remote
control parking option is handy for
those narrow spaces with precious little
room for the driver to exit the car
2015 sees the I go celebrate its 10th
year on the road it was co-developed by
Toyota with peugeot and citroen
specifically for the European market
with production based in curling in the
Czech Republic the three door entry
model is available in Germany for just
under 10,000 euros the second generation
like the first is aimed primarily at
younger car buyers
with compact and allison melissa to the
compact dimensions make it a decent City
Khan says I'm Andre low upkeep boosts
its appeal for first-time car owners and
as most my drivers who depended on a
cart tend to be based in the countryside
Andre is testing the I go out here the
engine is a 1-liter 3-cylinder gasoline
unit delivering 51 kilowatts and
accelerating to 100 km/h in 14 point two
seconds top speed is 160 kph official
fuel consumption is 4.1 litres per 100
kilometers
as it provides the naturally aspirated
three-cylinder engine does remind you
that it was designed for urban uses
Andre if you want to accelerate on a
country road you have to shift down a
gear or two and then really let it rip
what sounds like power is hot air the
Peugeot 108 of a Citroen c1 the sister
models have turbocharged engines out in
the country the Toyota AYGO sure could
do with a little of that d Werdum toyota
aygo after lunch classes a hella awkward
steam we put the 5-door edition through
its paces the side windows at the front
can be load right to the bottom but rear
passengers only have pop-out affairs but
Toyota didn't cut any corners when it
came to the seats in our version they
were leather clad both in the passenger
compartment and the trunk the new I go
has a little more space than a Viet
South key Andres is not only is his test
cars sat nav system and nicely displayed
he can even connect his mobile to it via
bluetooth and turn it into a car stereo
in hoc committee and as an option toyota
will install a Wi-Fi hotspot in the
glove compartment but the driver has to
resist the temptation to check social
media on the road social media coffee
nerds checking
the target group of younger car buyers
may have a hard time focusing on actual
reality long enough to pick the right
gear in the five-speed manual
transmission but the Eiger also comes
with an automatic driving the curves and
hills of country roads quickly reveals
this city cars limits
good mamita it's obvious to Andre that
the igo is designed for city driving the
steering for instance is a bit too
squishy for country roads but he's quite
satisfied with the gearshift it makes a
nice click when the gears catch though
some drivers may not appreciate the
extra muscle it takes and is concerned
that the uyghurs electronic stability
program can be turned off at the press
of a button inexperienced drivers tend
to overestimate themselves and shouldn't
be able to turn off the ESP so easily
making activity of my dad swoozie subash
edison when and ultimately not mr.
mukesh cake Kim does ESP hours to shout
the ESB is essential to help the driver
handle and keep control of the car in
terms of design the city car is anything
but bashful the conspicuous ex grill can
be toned down or brought out by the body
design options the rear contours are
just as bold but here real individualism
has its price
you buy from 15,000 oil Andre points out
that over fifteen thousand euros for an
i go with exclusive equipment is
relatively steep he wonders if anyone
really needs a leather seats in a city
car for that price he personally would
opt for the next higher model class it
may not have as many extras but it would
be more car for the money still for city
dwellers or new drivers or both combined
he'd recommend the I go unreservedly
into Anthea
the techno classica is the world's
largest vintage car fair this year in
spring almost 200,000 visitors made the
trek to Essen to oggle deep automotive
goodies or track down a part for their
own mechanical darling the classics
dealers and many vintage car clubs make
the fair a festival of nostalgia
this year's fab make is Ferrari
especially when it comes with a history
ferrari dealer helmet everline explains
that a car can be restored to the best
possible condition mechanically but it's
the history that gives a classic it's
true pedigree it can't be made up and it
can't be restored these cars are only
complete when they come with a history
that's what makes a car like this
something special and you can all do it
so you are many of the big car makers
make sure to get in on the spectacle
presenting choice specimens from their
own histories if a model has a jubilee
so much the better the Porsche 959 for
example is 30 years old this year and
already an icon of style and technology
the 959 and its successor the Carrera GT
blazed the trail for today's hybrid 918
spyder super sports car with an
impressive 900 horsepower or 652
kilowatts the Porsche 959 s cutaway
model appeals to more than just the
technology crowd
this 356b carrera too has already found
a new owner many car makers are proud to
be able to supply most of the parts
needed for their classics originally the
techno classica focused on cars at at
least 50 years behind them but that's
changed more and more newer models are
showing up the market is booming even if
tinkerers quickly reach their limits on
a beamers n1 or an 850 csiq play the
older vintage models aren't mechanical
marvels while the newer cars are all
about sophisticated electronics
the madness on the boxes answer foolish
clips has noticed that more and more
customers are looking for just those
sort of models it might be one of the
first BMW m4 or an m1 from the 1970s
many of the buyers know these cars from
their childhood or teenage years and now
they're looking back among the crowds
aetna techno classica our celebrities as
well such as World Cup winner or a torn
and Klaus Fischer former star player on
the German national soccer team
fashawn Lance's al-assad Oh laughs torn
says he and Klaus Fisher are just
looking around the t1 in the background
is the same age as Klaus Fisher 65 it's
fun for them to see these beautiful old
cars again to alter smart video says in
another Jubilee is the BW Paolo's 40th
this man has one of the newer models the
polocrosse with lots of accessories and
extras he really enjoys driving it
around town the studs push begun does
she enjoy seeing cult cars cuz used to
be more colorful
look we'll see her this gentleman wishes
today's carmakers would be a little
bolder when it comes to paint everything
seems to be gray or black nowadays